Це - чотирилапий солдат Національної гвардії України на прізвисько Білка...
Його тренує тендітна жінка.
Ще два роки тому тут, у кінологічному центрі Нацгвардії, служили виключно чоловіки.
Тепер тут командує молодша сержантка Вікторія Безус.
Під її керівництвом - 37 собак і 37 солдатів-строковиків.
Їх усіх треба навчити проводити розшукові дії, затримувати злочинців.
Це можливо лише за умови, якщо і люди, і тварини
навчаться бути одним цілим - слухатися, розуміти, відчувати одне одного.
Вони усі дресуються, як і собаки.
Це так - жарт.Я думаю, ніхто не образиться
Це насправді не жарт, і чоловіки не ображаються.
Адже кінологічна служба - це, по суті, справді дресура.
До того ж Вікторія тут авторитет.
У свої тридцять три вона зробила блискавичну кар'єру.
З цивільної посади бухгалтера-економіста
за два роки стала заступницею командира кінологічного центру.
І все завдяки її успіхам в кінологічному спорті.
Швидше знімайте намордники, обираємо дистанцію.
Добре. Ви четверо тут. Троє там.
У2015 роціРадбез ООН ухвалив резолюцію "Жінки.Мир. Безпека".
На ії виконання в Україні затвердили Національний план дій
і почали залучати більше жінок до правоохоронної та військової діяльності,
а також сприяти жіночому лідерствув цих структурах.
Тепер для жінок відкриті майже усі спеціальності, які раніше було суто чоловічими.
Кінологи, льотчики, командири в морській піхоті і на флоті.
Вікторія - за гендерну рівноправність, але проти відбору лише за статевим критерієм.
Якщо є в цьому потреба -в спеціалісті,
і цей спеціаліст - жінка, то, так, потрібно.
Я вважаю, що не треба брати просто за статевим критерієм спеціаліста.
У Нацгвардії наразі приблизно 4500 жінок, за даними служби з гендерної інтеграції.
Бажаючих посісти раніше традиційно чоловічі посади багато.
Аліна Даданєнко прийшла у кінологічний центр з МНС
Як і Вікторія, вона на командирській посаді - керує відділенням.
Каже, гендерні зміни в Нацгвардії ставлять нові виклики і перед самими жінками
Від них вимагається не лише перепідготовка чи-то додаткове навчання.
Те, що вимагають від чоловіка, вже вимагають і від жінки на рівні з чоловіком
Немає якби такого, скажімо, ти там жінка - не будеш те робити, будеш те.
Такого немає.
Активні гендерні зміни в Нацгвардії розпочалися фактично цьогоріч.
Вікторія і Аліна, за рівнем освіти і професійних навичок,
вже зараз можуть претендувати на підвищення,
але в інших підрозділах Нацгвардії.
Поки ж обирають службу,
де отримують задоволення від роботи з чотирилапими бійцями.